scientists from around the world have
come together in support of a ban on
nuclear weapons nuclear arms are the
only weapons of mass destruction not yet
prohibited by an international
convention even though they are the most
destructive and indiscriminate weapons
ever created and scientists bear a
special responsibility for nuclear
weapons since it was scientists who
invented them and who discovered that
their effects are even more horrific
than first thought
nuclear weapons represent one of the
greatest threats to our civilization and
to all life on Earth
I said nuclear weapons are the only
weapons of mass destruction not yet
prohibited by an international
convention now this is the moment for
such as conservation to me the idea of
having countries the world get together
and decide to ban nuclear weapons in the
same way they had conventions to ban
chemical weapons biological weapons and
other things makes a tremendous amount
of sense over a decade ago George Shultz
convene a meeting in Stanford at that
meeting we reflected back on the
Reykjavik summit meeting where Reagan
and Gorbachev discussed the possibility
of a total elimination of nuclear
weapons
I'm meeting at Stanford to determine
whether it would be visiting that idea
and we concluded that a watch
many states want to keep their nukes for
deterrence despite being bound by the
non-proliferation treaty to give them up
invested but some maintain dangerous
rock piles vastly exceeding deterrence
requirements and for developing new
destabilizing ones with better first
strike capacity the world should agree
and declare that this is not acceptance
the UN treaty borders obviously aren't
naive and think that a ban will
magically rid the world of nuclear
weapons but the bad will add stigma
which has the first step will pressure
that include power
/ to access the horizont under the
minimum level needed returns which would
be a great step in the right direction
not banning nuclear weapons or different
the decision to later generations will
render the situation highly unstable or
meta stable as we physicists say it's
something that is long overdue but the
sooner we can do it the better because
it will make the world a far safer place
there is nothing more tempting to reduce
violence than to have powerful weapons
in the hands of people who may not have
complete responsibility for this
significance those weapons I'm Steven
Pinker I am a professor of psychology at
Harvard University and I support the ban
and I support the ban jury because the
nuclear non-proliferation treaty has not
succeeded in getting the nuclear weapon
state to hold up their part of the
bargain so I'm strongly in support of an
international ban on nuclear weapons
I support the ban on all nuclear weapons
for the future of our planet today the
United Nations is continuing Advan on
with your weapons political effect of
that bans and by no means clear but
tomorrow of that is quite clear what
we're saying is there ought to be a band
under the Elevens individual explosions
can obliterate cities radioactive
fallout can contaminate regions and a
high-altitude electromagnetic pulse may
cause mayhem by frying electrical grids
and electronics across the continent the
preamble to the ban treaty mentions the
humanitarian impacts of nuclear weapons
as a reason to ban them if we use
nuclear weapons we can produce a nuclear
winter sentencing most of the planet to
starvation from the effects of the smoke
fires from burning cities or the weapons
explode lies is hiding to the atmosphere
the smoke blocks sunlight the
consequence of planet cools off so much
that agriculture is damaged which would
lead to mass starvation of a planet and
probably kill a large fraction of the
people
over the world even outside the
combatant countries even a very small
nuclear war would cause tremendous
disruption to the world's food supply if
we want to avoid the dangers of nuclear
war the dangers of accidental nuclear
explosions and the incredible costs to
upgrade and keep a huge nuclear arsenal
we need to design the only solution to
this problem is to get rid of nuclear
weapons I support them Andrea I
completely support a ban I support the
proposed ban on nuclear weapons a
nuclear war is more likely than one may
hope because it can start by mistake
miscalculation or terrorist provocation
there is a steady stream of accidents
and false alarms that could trigger
all-out war and relying on neverending
luck is not a sustainable strategy but
the UN negotiations to ban nuclear
weapons offer a new source of optimism
over 3,700 scientists from 100 countries
have signed an open letter in support of
the ban and urging their governments to
do the same because nuclear weapons
threaten not merely those who have them
but all people on earth
as a mother and bind it I wish you good
luck with the negotiation the world and
future generation depend on you
you
[Music]